the American Financial system is in
crisis recession recession full-blown
recession but Mr Beast seems to be doing
fine I'm gonna hand each of you a check
for fifty thousand dollars so what does
he know that the rest of us don't get
that 300 000 car global economy could
fall into recession
fed and other central banks raise
interest rates in an effort to stop
inflation
I was recently talking with some other
YouTubers and they asked me how the
recession would affect creators it's a
good question and we don't really have
much history to draw from here because
the last time there was a major
financial crisis YouTube was only a few
years old now tons of creators have
built independent video businesses so if
a recession causes ad revenue and
sponsorships to dry up they could be in
a really tough situation let's analyze
Jimmy's business to understand this
recession and its impact on the Creator
economy here's what we know so far the
United States economy is going into a
recession and inflation is at 40-year
Highs but here's the really interesting
thing when I listen to Mr Beast talk
about his business sounds more like
someone teaching at Harvard Business
School than a College Dropout with a
YouTube channel there's no such thing as
a perfect video like someone should
always call you and [ __ ] on your video
because it could be better like Imagine
The Compound Effect over that time span
it's it's invaluable he has really
mastered the business side of YouTube so
creators should be studying this stuff
extremely closely because anyone can use
his tactics let's start with the most
basic element of his business his main
Channel videos any Channel with more
than a thousand subscribers can start
earning money from YouTube AdSense
before a video plays YouTube shows an ad
and pays the Creator a portion of the
earnings when you're bringing in
billions of views like Mr Beast this can
quickly add up to millions of dollars
but there's a problem see recently there
was a change to the way these ads get
tracked and it's reducing the amount of
money that goes to creators like Mr
Beast when Apple launched iOS 14 they
included a pop-up notification that
asked the user if they wanted to be
tracked while using a particular app the
idea was to give iPhone users more
control over their privacy but it had
some big implications for creators the
pop-up gives you two options you can
either ask app not to track or allow
tracking disabling tracking doesn't
really change anything about the app
you're using so most people click ask
app not to track the problem is that now
advertisers don't know if their ads are
effective so they wind up spending less
This only affects iPhone users but a lot
of people watch YouTube on iPhones I
just looked at my own YouTube analytics
and basically 20 of the audience is
watching on iPhones this number is only
growing though and it's already having a
big impact Google owns YouTube but when
they report their financials they still
separate out Google search from YouTube
ad revenue and by looking at the
difference we can predict how creators
will be affected and here's where it
gets worrying YouTube's ad business is
underperforming right now while Google
search is doing better than expected
when you watch a Mr Beast video on an
iPhone you're probably watching it in
the YouTube app during that video a
YouTube ad plays but you probably won't
click on the ad you need to see the end
of that video after all but maybe later
on you'll go and check out the company
in the ad and maybe even make a purchase
normally the company would be able to
recognize that you saw an ad during that
Mr Beast video and link your purchase to
that ad but not anymore now Google
Search Works differently most people use
Google search in a browser and apple
can't block tracking there but this
doesn't help creators since they aren't
the ones powering Google search what
this means is that advertisers are
pulling back from YouTube and shifting
to Google search ads these are the
brands that ultimately pay for the ads
that fund so many great channels on
YouTube so this could really hurt
creators if the trend continues but Mr
Beast has thought ahead and uses two
strategies to maximize the amount of AD
Revenue he makes from each video Once a
Mr Beast video goes live he doesn't just
let it sit there he instantly starts
translating it into as many languages as
possible in order to maximize his reach
ninety percent of my the world can't
even watch this stuff
this will ultimately increase the amount
of money YouTube pays him for a given
video instead of worrying about a
potential drop in the amount of money he
gets for a single view on YouTube Mr
Beast is proactively going out and
getting more views for his content but
he doesn't stop there he's actually
started working with Financial Partners
to sell the rights to Future revenue
streams from videos in his back catalog
he gets a big check up front to fund his
operations and scale up his business in
exchange for the future ad Revenue that
will come in from an old video it's a
great deal for him and it could help
smooth out cash flows if the recession
leads to a slump in part of his business
AdSense is just a small piece of most
businesses built on YouTube these days
though and for good reason the ads that
YouTube runs during a video are hard to
track and they have no real connection
to the personality on display in the
video but that leads us to how Mr Beast
changed the art of the brand deal
advertisers don't care about showing an
ad to millions of people if no one
actually goes and buys their product and
as we've seen it's getting harder and
harder to track the ads that YouTube
automatically places in videos but brand
deals get around this issue when Mr
Beast mentions a sponsor in a video he
doesn't just throw the logo up on the
screen and expect you to go buy the
product he always shouts out a specific
coupon code that you should use at
checkout this allows the brand to know
with certainty that a specific customer
bought because they watched a Mr Beast
video now this is basic stuff but Mr
Beast actually takes it several steps
further when he did a deal with Shopify
for his 100 million subscriber special
he actually directed his audience to go
to shopify.com mrbeast this is a custom
landing page with videos of Jimmy and
his team to further convince you that
you should use the service it's
perfectly trackable for Shopify so they
know the exact value of that brand deal
this is what's called direct response
advertising and in times of economic
uncertainty it becomes much more popular
brands want to know that every dollar
they spend is returning a profit at the
end of the day and these direct response
advertisements do just that the
alternative to direct response
advertising is brand marketing where a
company pays to put their brand in front
of lots of people but can't really track
what happens afterward think about a
company putting their logo on a Formula
One car clearly it's going to draw
attention to the brand but it's going to
be impossible to tell if seeing the logo
fly by at 200 miles per hour was the
reason that someone purchased Mr Beast
has become a master of direct response
marketing by using a few key tricks
first off he only partners with
companies that fit with his personal
brand and ultimately his audience he
actually uses Shopify to sell merch and
other products so it makes sense that he
would promote the service he also knows
how to integrate the sponsorship in a
way that won't hurt viewer retention
YouTube only promotes videos that people
are watching to the end so if he
completely stopped the video to tell you
about the sponsor lots of viewers would
either skip that section of the video or
get distracted and move on to something
else entirely but when Jimmy's starts
talking about a brand he constantly
switches between the ad read and the
actual challenge in the video for that
Shopify ad he gives you one fact about
Shopify and then switches back to having
the next contestant walk the plank you
can't skip through the ad read or else
you'll miss the entire challenge now if
the economy gets worse we might see
these brand sponsorships begin to dry up
but this recession isn't like previous
economic downturns see even though the
US economy has been shrinking it's still
over 99 percent as big as it was six
months ago so we're not going through a
total collapse at the moment and perhaps
more importantly certain portions of the
economy are actually still growing it's
important to look at the split between
goods like cars furniture and other
physical stuff and services like gym
memberships restaurants and even
e-commerce software like Shopify during
the pandemic people stopped going out so
Services fell off a cliff instead of
paying for a gym membership people
bought workout equipment for use at home
and instead of going out to movie
theaters people bought bigger TV
it was a big shift from services to
Goods now that the pandemic is over the
pendulum is swinging back the other
direction and services are growing while
durable goods are shrinking and this is
another place where Mr Beast is very
well positioned over the past year he's
only done brand Partnerships with
service-based businesses Shopify for
e-commerce current for credit cards
Experian for credit monitoring and the
brawl Stars mobile game all of these are
Services businesses that are likely to
continue making money even in a
recession but the really interesting
thing about Jimmy's brand deal strategy
is how few he does out of his last 16
videos only six had brand sponsors you
might think he's leaving money on the
table but he's actually just employing
another key strategy for profit
maximization selling his own products in
order for a brand integration to work
both the Creator and Company sponsoring
the video need to make money this
creates a problem though when Mr Beast
promotes a company he doesn't capture
all of the profit he generates for that
business if he did there would be no
point the business to sponsor the video
but by building his own businesses from
the ground up he avoids this problem
that's what he's done with both
feastables and Beast Burger he owns
those Brands and doesn't need to
negotiate a revenue share to promote
them both these businesses are
fascinating because of how they
demonstrate Jimmy's understanding of his
audience chocolate bars and hamburgers
are basically the most popular food
items in the world they're everywhere
and this Cuts both ways on the one hand
many people would say that both markets
are extremely crowded which should make
it hard to compete how can Mr Beast be
expected to compete with Snickers and
McDonald's when both of those companies
have billions of dollars at their
disposal well it comes back to his brand
integration strategy when McDonald's
wants to advertise they need to pay
someone to do it they don't own their
own media channels I mean McDonald's
does technically have a YouTube channel
but it's not exactly posting bangers so
when Mr Beast can advertise his products
essentially for free he can drive growth
in those businesses and this is
something that's really important for
creators to understand building a
business that you can advertise on your
own Channel for free allows you to
basically capture twice as much value as
partnering with an existing brand we're
going to be seeing a lot more of these
Creator owned businesses in the future
because every Creator should look at
what brands are sponsoring them and see
if it's possible to build their own
version Jimmy is now in a hiring Blitz
even while many companies are doing
layoffs he's made everyone reconsider
how big a YouTube business can get and
that's why Silicon Valley billionaires
are constantly shouting them out so if
you want to fully understand his
playbook for scaling a YouTube business
like a Silicon Valley startup just watch
this video next